Tụi tịch cuối hội trên tháng mẫn đặt ký bán thành y ký cú cuối hội về kế hoạch phát triển kinh tế,
xác hội năm 2020, đặt mục tiêu tăng trưởng ZDP từ mối phần chăm trở lên,
ZDP bình quân đầu người đặt năm 1997 đến năm 1997, Tại trọng công nghiệp chia biến,
chia tạo trong ZDP khoảng 2,5% về C-mê sáo phần chăm, C-P-E bình quân khoảng 4,5%
Nhi ký cư diễn mạnh hoàn thiện pháp lột về đầu tư, kinh gióanh, đưa thể chế trở thành đột phá của đột phá và lợi thế cạnh tranh cúch ra.
Cú hội yêu cầu cắt giám đơn giản hóa một trong phần chăm điều kiện đầu tư kinh giành không cần thiết, trong cháo bãi bỏ điều kiện với ngành,
nhi không thuộc xanh một có điều kiện. Giám năm 1997,
giải quyết và ghi phí tên tụ tụ tụi tụi thành chính xói với năm 1997.
Đăng chú ý, nhi quyết yêu cầu đánh giá công chức theo thư C-P-E, C-P lột, kỳ cư, kinh quyết khóc phục tình chẳng nế chẳng,
đuôn đầy, sợ chắc nhận, coi khóa học, công nghệ đổi mới sáng tạo,
chuyển đổi số lại động lực chính của mô hình tăng trường mới.